hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to another high definition video
and today we're going to be taking a
look at the monster eye clarity hd
bluetooth speaker system and i got to
get this off my chest the speaker system
actually really impressed me uh that
i've been testing in the last couple
days and i really liked it but first
thing i want to show you guys is my
phone now why am i showing you my phone
well this actually is one of the few
cases where it works with bluetooth on
an android device or something that's
not an ipod or iphone so i'm actually
going to turn on bluetooth here and go
ahead to our wireless settings in our
android device we'll actually go ahead
and test this out and i'll show you guys
how quickly and easy
easily this is to set up
so i'll go ahead and turn this on to the
back over on the back i'll give you a
quick hardware tour there's your on off
switch we'll turn this on there's also
the usb charging and it comes with a
white usb cable i didn't do an unboxing
because it's just this and the cable but
you get a usb charging cable and an
audio in for devices that don't have
bluetooth you can see at the top it's a
monster micro bluetooth speaker this
over at the top here was covered as you
can see it's very glossy but it's made
of metal and it's of high build quality
in the front you have two one inch
drivers that look pretty good on the
front here there's also some rubber feet
at the bottom so in order to pair this
you can go ahead and take a look at the
left hand side we have a power button a
call button or you can answer calls and
turning up and down volume we want to do
is go ahead and hold this down
and keep holding after it turns on
and it'll go ahead and turn into pair
mode
now while that's in pair mode we'll go
ahead and take a look at our android
device and we can scan for devices we
already have the monster i clarity here
which is really fast go ahead and pair
that and it'll connect it and we'll be
able to play all of our audio from our
phone be able to take calls while it's
docked and charging things like that
so you can see in the background here it
was already connected and ready to go so
hopefully that view gives you a good
idea of how easy that is
now go ahead and take a look at the
speaker itself
go ahead and zoom in here it is of a
very high build quality i have
absolutely no complaints go ahead and
zoom down no complaints about sound
quality build quality it's been nicely
constructed well put together what it's
actually made of is a it's a very uh
nicely reconstructed plastic it's not
metal which would have probably been the
next step up but for the price that
you're paying for this i really do think
plastic is is just about as nice as you
need to be so i'm going to go ahead and
do is go ahead and play some uh uh very
well i don't think i can actually play
music because as you guys know youtube
is not that great without copyrights but
if i were to go ahead and open up the
beginning of a song here so that i don't
get in trouble for copyrights you'll see
that this speaker is really really quick
to connect so what i have is a little
song
over here in the foreground it's a
little green album cover and we'll go
ahead and turn
this volume all the way down so we can
play it
we'll go ahead and start over the song
so it was that fast to connect so if you
want to go ahead and play something for
your friends on this speaker it's going
to be really fast to connect you don't
have to worry about buffering times or
having a slow boot bluetooth connection
it's always going to be top notch
so getting into the build quality like i
mentioned before it's of high build
quality on the top you have this very
high end plastic
i wouldn't really call it like cheap
plastic since it is you know you can tap
it and it's not going to break it's nice
and glossy but it actually does attract
fingerprints very easily you can see it
says monster on the top there
it's really nice you can see in the
front here your status lights so
hopefully this light won't get in the
way of the camera but you can see the
status lights when you saw that i was
pairing it you can see that was blinking
a bunch of different blue and red colors
and when you're solid you're not pairing
it or you're just using it
to play something you can actually use
uh
it'll just be a solid blue color so i
think that's really cool that it works
with more than just ios devices a lot of
bluetooth speakers you saw me review the
solar sound two not too long ago that
really wasn't the best compatibility
with the motorola droid and believe me i
tried it so uh this has been the review
of the eye clarity hd from monster cable
which is finally provided for them to
review i've been i gotta say very very
impressed with this speaker system and
i'm going to go ahead and give this an 8
and a half out of 10 by my review
standards thanks for checking out this
review of the monster i clarity hd can't
wait to keep using this in the future
until then mkbhd signing out
peace